[Musique]
posté par c'est ce
cas
d'accord
avec didier crois moi c'est pas de locon
beaumont pacte
il n'y a pas d'eau ici frère ou
anti roms c'est certes un
grand cru monsieur didier
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
baisse en trois versions artistes baisse
un doigt s'était déjà été numéro un
bassin doit si tu passes ta vie dans les
hôtels baisse 1,3 étaient du genre à
réenregistrer mille fois une chanson en
studio baisse un doigt star hantise est
de tomber sur scène baisse un doigt si
on va déjà envoyé une demande en mariage
baisse en droit c'est quand tu passes le
million stream qui sautent de joie
baisse en toi si tu galères à trouver
des tenues pour thé chaud bassin doit
s'était déjà regretter d'avoir fait un
feat bessane ouest a déjà vidé le mini
bar d'un hôtel en tournée et baisse un
doigt si un éditeur stade déjà en bruit
dans la rue
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]